The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Monday's lecture
was all linear equations.
And I thought I
would start today
with nonlinear equations,
still first order.
And we can't deal with
every nonlinear equation.
That's too much to ask.
These are going
to be made easier
by a property
called "separable."
So these will be separable
nonlinear equations.
And let me start with
a couple of examples
and then you'll
see the whole idea.
So one example would be the
simplest nonlinear equation
I can think of,
with a y squared.
So how to get there?
Here's the trick.
This is the separable idea.
You're going to
see it in one shot.
We can separate, put
the Ys on one side
and the Ds on the other.
So I write this as dy
over y squared equal dt.
I put the dt up and
brought the y squared down.
So now they're
separated, in a kind
of hookie way with
infinitesimals.
But I'll makes sense out
of that by integrating.
I'll integrate both sides.
I'll integrate time from 0 to t.
And I have an initial
condition, y of 0, always.
And since this one is about y,
when t starts at 0, this guy
starts at y of 0, up
to, this ends at t,
so this ends at y of t.
OK.
Now the point is, also
the problem was nonlinear,
we've got two separate
ordinary integrals to do.
And we can do them.
We can certainly do
the right hand side.
I get t.
And on the left hand
side, what do I get?
Well, that maybe I better
leave a little space
to figure out this one.
But the point is we can
integrate 1 over y squared.
And I guess we get
minus 1 over y.
So I get minus 1 over y
between y of 0 and y of t.
In other words, I'm
getting let's see,
so what the right, the
derivative of the integral of 1
over y squared is minus
1 over y because I always
check the derivative
gives me that back.
So now I'm ready to
plug-in those limits.
So I'll do the
bottom limit first
because it comes with a minus
sign, canceling that minus, 1
over y of 0 minus 1 over y of t.
Got it.
And that equals the other
integral, which is just t.
So that's the answer as it
comes directly from integration.
And we can do more.
You can see that finding the
solution when these things are
separable has boiled
down to two integrals.
And we could have a
function of t here, too.
And that would be
allowed, a function of t
multiplying this
guy, because then I
would leave the function
of t on that side.
And I would have
to integrate that.
And I would bring the y.
You see, I've just
separated the y.
In general, these
equations look like dy, dt
is some function of t divided
by some function of y.
Maybe the book
calls the top one g,
I think, and the bottom one f.
And everybody in this room
sees that I can put the f of y
up there.
I can put the dt up there.
And I've separated it.
OK.
So that's sort of the
general situation.
This is a kind of nice example,
nice example, dy, dt equals
y squared.
Can we just play with
this a little bit?
Let me take y of 0 to be 1,
just to make the numbers easy.
So if y of 0 is 1,
then I have, I'll
just keep going a little bit.
You do have to keep
going a little bit
because when you finish
the integral right there,
you haven't got y equal.
You've got some equation
that involves y,
but you have to solve for y.
So I have to solve
that equation for y.
Let me just do it.
So how would I solve it?
And let me take y of 0 to be 1.
So now, if I just write
it below, I'm at 1 minus 1
over y equals t.
Good?
So I'm going to put the 1 over
y of t on that side and the t
on that side.
So if I just continue here,
I've got 1 over y of t
on this side and, do I have
1 minus t on that side?
Yeah.
Looking good.
So solution starting from
y of 0 equal 1 is y of t
equal 1 over 1 minus t.
You could do that.
And I can always, like, mentally
I check the algebra at t
equals 0.
That gives me the answer, 1.
But let's step back and
look at that answer.
I mean, that's part of
differential equations
is to do some algebra, if
possible, and get to a formula.
But if we don't think
about the formula,
we haven't learned anything.
Right there, yes.
Good.
So what happens?
I want to compare with
the linear case that
was like e to the t.
This was y prime equal y, right?
And that led to e to the t.
Y prime equals y squared
leads to that one.
So first observation.
I haven't got exponentials
anymore in that solution.
Exponentials are
just like perfection
for linear equations.
For nonlinear equations,
we get other functions.
Professor Fry had a
hyperbolic tangent function
in his first lecture.
Other things happen.
OK.
Now, how do those
compare if I graph those?
It's just like, why not try?
So they both started at 1.
And e to the t went
up exponentially.
E to the t.
And, I don't know,
we use exponential.
In our minds, we think,
that's pretty fast growth.
! mean, that's the common
expression, grew exponentially.
But here, this guy
is going to grow
faster because y is going
to be bigger than 1.
So y squared is going
to be bigger than y.
That one's going to grow faster.
Faster than exponential.
This has the exponential growth.
Pretty fast.
Polynomial, of course,
some parabola or something
would be hanging way down
here, left behind in the dust.
But this 1 over
1 minus t, that's
going to grow really fast.
And what's more, it's
going to go to infinity.
So that y prime equal
y squared, the solution
to that doesn't
just-- e to the t
goes to infinity
at time infinity.
At any finite time,
we get an answer.
Eventually, at t equal infinity,
it's gone above every bound.
But this one, 1 over 1 minus
t is what I want to graph now.
I believe that that takes
off and at a certain point,
capital T, it's
going to infinity.
It's blown up.
So it's blow up in finite time.
Blow up in finite time.
And what is that time?
What's the time at which the
y prime equal y squared has
taken off, gone off the charts?
T equal--
AUDIENCE: 1.
PROFESSOR: --1.
Because when t reaches
1, I have 1 over 0,
and I'm dividing by 0,
and so that's the blow up.
Finite time blow up.
OK.
So this can happen for
some nonlinear equations.
It wouldn't happen
for a linear equation.
For a linear equation,
exponentials are in control.
OK.
So that's one nice example.
Oh, another nice thing
about that example.
Well, I say nice if you're
OK with infinite series.
I just want to compare.
The book mentions the
infinite series for these guys
because that's an old way to
solve differential equations is
term-by-term in an
infinite series.
It's sort of fun to
see the two series.
Well, because they're the two
most important series in math.
Actually, they're the two series
that everybody should know.
The power series,
Taylor series--
whatever word you want to
give it for those two guys.
So let me do them.
E to the t, I'll put that one
first, and 1 over 1 minus t.
These are the great
series of math.
Shall I just write them down
and sort of talk through them?
Because this is not a lecture
on infinite series by any means.
But having these
two in front of us,
coming from these two
beautiful equations,
y prime equal y squared
and y prime equal y,
I can't resist seeing what
they look like this way.
So e to the t, do you
remember e to the t?
It starts at 1.
What's the slope of e to the t?
At t equals 0.
So I'm doing everything--
this series is
going to be, both
of the series are
going to be, around t equals 0.
That's my, like, starting point.
So this e to the t
thing has a tangent.
It has a slope there.
And what's the slope of
e to the t at t equals 0?
AUDIENCE: 1.
PROFESSOR: 1.
It's derivative.
The derivative of e to
the t is e to the t.
The slope is 1.
So that tangent line
has coefficient 1.
That's how it starts.
That's the linear approximation.
That's the heart of
calculus, is this.
But we're going to go better.
We're going to
get the next term.
So what's the next term?
That gave us the tangent line.
Now I'm going to move
to the tangent parabola.
So the parabola has
got another is still
going to be below
the real thing.
Can I squeeze in the
words "line" and "parab,"
for "parabola?"
Parabola has bending.
I'm really explaining
the Taylor series
in what I hope is
a sensible way.
Here is the starting point.
This has the slope.
The next term has the bending.
The bending comes
from what derivative?
What derivative tells
us about bending?
Second derivative.
Second derivative tells
us how much it curves.
Well, the second derivative of
e to the t is still e to the t.
So the bending is 1.
The bending is also 1.
Now that comes in with
a factor of a 1/2.
There is the tangent parabola.
And you will see what
these numbers become.
Let me just go to,
the third derivative
would be responsible
for the t cubed term.
And its coefficient would
be 1 over 3 factorial.
So 2 is the same as 2 factorial.
3 factorial is 3
times 2 times 16.
So the numbers here go 1, 6, 24,
120, whatever the next one is.
720 or something.
They grow fast.
So that series always
gives a finite answer.
It does grow with t.
But it doesn't spike with t.
Now compare that famous series.
And of course, this
is 1 over 1 factorial,
everything consistent.
Compare that with the
series for 1 over 1 minus t.
That's the other famous series
that they learned in algebra.
I'll just write it.
That's 1 plus t plus t
squared plus t cubed plus 1
so on, with coefficient 1.
This had 1 over n factorials.
Those make the series converge.
These don't have
the n factorials.
This is 1, 1, 1, 1.
And, well, I could
check that formula.
But do you remember the
name for that series?
1 plus t plus t squared
plus t cubed plus so on?
Algebra is taught differently
in many high schools now.
And maybe that never got a name.
I guess I would call it
the Geometric series.
Geometric series.
And you see, it's beautiful.
It's the other important series.
But it's quite
different from this one
because, what's the
difference about this series?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It goes to infinity.
PROFESSOR: It's a--
PROFESSOR: It goes to infinity.
But where?
At what time?
At what value of t is this
sum going to fall apart?
Blow up?
At t equal 1.
When have 1 plus 1 plus 1
plus 1, I'm getting infinity.
So this blows up.
And of course, we see that it
should because this blows up.
Left side blows up at t equal
1, the right side blows up a t
equal 1.
Where the exponential
series, which
is the heart of ordinary
differential equations,
never blows up because of these
big numbers in the denominator.
OK, I'm good for this first
simple example, y prime equals
y squared.
It has so much in it,
it's worth thinking about.
I'm ready, you OK
for a second example?
A second important
separable equation.
I'm going to pick one.
So I'm going to pick an
equation that starts out
with our familiar linear growth.
This could be, you
know, last time
it was growth of
money in a bank.
It could be growth
of population.
The number of, to a sum
first approximation,
the rate of growth
of the population
comes from, like,
births minus deaths.
And with modern medicine,
births are a larger number
than deaths.
So a is positive,
and that grows.
But if we're talking
about the, I mean,
the United Nations
tries to predict,
everybody tries to
predict, population
of the world in future years.
And so this could be called
the Population Equation.
But just to leave it as pure
exponential is obviously wrong.
The world can't grow forever.
The population
can't grow forever.
And the, I guess I hope it
doesn't grow like 1 over 1
minus t.
So this is at least
a little slower.
But somehow competition for
space, competition for food,
for oil, for water-- which
is going to be the big one--
is in here.
Competition here, of
people versus people,
a reasonable term, a
first approximation,
is a y squared, with a
minus, is a y squared
and with some coefficient.
That's a very famous equation.
A first model of
population is it grows.
But this is a competition
term, y against y.
And so, the same
would be true if we
were talking about epidemics.
That's a big subject with
ordinary differential
equations, epidemiology.
Or say, flu.
How does flu spread?
And how does it get cured?
So partly, people are
getting over the flu.
But then y against y is
telling us how many infected,
how many new infections.
So we would like to
solve that equation.
And it's separable.
I can do what I did
before, dy over ay minus by
squared equal dt.
And I can integrate,
starting from year of 0.
Well, why don't we
start from year 2014,
with the population y at
now-- the present population?
That would be a model that
the UN would consider using.
That other people with
very important interest
in measuring population and
measuring every resource
would need equations like this.
And then they would
put on more terms,
like a term for immigration.
All sorts, many improvements
have to go into this equation.
Let me just look
at this as it is.
Well, I've got two choices here.
Well, it's this integral
that I'm looking at.
That is a doable integral.
It's the type of integral that
we saw in the Rocket problem.
The Rocket problem was
more constant minus.
This was a drag term, when
we were looking at rockets.
And this was a
constant, say, gravity.
So it was still a second degree.
Still second degree,
but a little different.
This has the linear in
second degree terms.
If you look up that
integral, you'll find it.
Or there's a systematic
way to do it.
That's in 1801, I guess,
called partial fractions.
It's not a lot of fun.
I don't plan to do it.
It's in the book.
Has to be because that's
the way you can integr-- you
can integrate polynomials
over polynomials
by partial fractions.
That's what they're
for, but there's
a neat way to do this one.
There's a neat trick
that Bernoulli discovered
to solve that equation, to
turn it into a linear equation.
And of course, if we can turn
it into a linear equation,
we're on our way.
So the neat trick is
let z be 1 over y.
You can put this in the
category of lucky accidents,
if you like.
So now I want an equation for z.
So I know that dz, dt if I
take the derivative of that,
that's y to the minus 1.
So it's minus 1 y to
the minus 2 dy, dt.
That's the chain rule.
Take the derivative of 1 over 1,
you get minus 1 over y squared.
Multiply by the derivative
of what's inside.
That's the chain rule.
OK.
So I plan to substitute
those in here.
So dy, dt, let's see.
Can you see me?
You can probably do
it better than me.
So dy, dt is minus.
I'll bring that up.
Dy, dt I'm going to
put-- I hope this'll
work all right-- for dy,
dt, I'm going to put in dz.
Using this, I'm going to
put minus y squared dz, dt.
Did that look right?
I don't think I'm
necessarily doing
this the most brilliant way.
But dy, dt-- I put this up here
and I got that-- equals ay.
So that's a over z.
Oh, y Is 1 over z.
So get this, I want all Zs now.
So that's this part.
And ay is over z
minus by squared
is minus b over z squared.
Would you say OK to that?
I've got Zs now, instead of Ys.
I just took every term and
replaced y by 1 over z.
Y is 1 over z and dy,
dt I can get that way.
OK.
Yeah.
Now what?
Now look what happens, if I
multiply through by z squared
or by minus z squared.
Let me multiply through
by minus z squared.
I get dz, dt.
Multiplying by minus z
squared gives me a minus az.
And what do I get
when I multiply
this one by minus z squared?
AUDIENCE: Plus b.
PROFESSOR: I get plus b.
Look what happened.
By this, like, some magic trick.
You could say, all right.
That was just a one time shot.
But it was a good one.
We ended up with a
linear equation for z.
A linear equation for z.
And we solved that
equation last time.
So let me squeeze in
the solution for z,
and then elsewhere.
So what was the
solution for z of t?
It was some multiple
of, no, yeah.
This is perfect
review of last time.
We have a constant times z.
And so that's going to
go into the exponential.
This will be the, it's
a minus a, notice.
That will be the, what
part of the solution
is that one called?
That's the null solution.
The null solution, when b is o.
And now I add in a
particular solution.
A particular solution.
And one good particular
solution is choose the z
to be a constant.
Then that'll be 0.
So I want that to be 0.
So what constant z makes that 0?
I think it's b
over a, don't you?
I think b over a.
Does that work good?
That's every null solution
plus one particular solution.
Let me say now,
and I'll say again,
looking for solutions which
are steady states, b over
a-- of this particular solution,
that particular solution made
this 0.
So it made this 0.
So it's a solution that's
not going anywhere.
It's a constant solution.
It's a solution that
can live for all time.
OK.
B over a.
Let me put that word
there, steady state.
OK.
And now I would want to match
the initial conditions using c.
Yeah.
I'd better do that.
OK.
And I have to get back to y.
I have y is 1 over z.
So I'm going to have to
flip this upside down.
I'm going to have to
flip this upside down is
what will actually happen.
Let me make it easy to flip.
Let me, I'll change c,
which is just some constant
to some constant d over a.
So then it's a is
everywhere down below.
And I just write it
here in the middle.
That makes it easier to flip.
So finally I get their solution.
Solution to the
population equation.
But that's the famous word
for it, the Logistic equation.
This is section 1.7 of the
text on the differential
equations in linear algebra.
It's a very, very
much studied example.
It's a great example.
It fits the growth of
human population with some,
it's our first
level approximation
to growth of or other
populations or other things.
It's a linear term giving
us exponential growth,
and a quadratic term of
competition slowing it down.
And let's see that slow down.
So now that was
a bit of algebra.
Much nicer than
partial fractions.
The bit of algebra just came
from this idea of going to z.
And now I want to go back to y.
So y is 1 over z.
So it's a over d e to
the minus at plus b.
That's our solution.
A and b came out
of the equation.
And d is going to
be the number that
makes the initial value correct.
So at t equals 0, I would
have y of 0, whatever
the initial population
is, is a over d.
T Is 0, so that's just 1 plus b.
So that tells me what d is.
D equals something.
It comes from y of 0.
So the answer, let me
circle that answer.
That answer has three
numbers in it, a, b, and d.
a and b come from the equation.
D also involves the
initial starting thing,
which is exactly what it showed.
So you could say
we've solved it.
But if you ever solve
an equation like this,
you want to graph it.
You want to graph it.
So let me draw its graph.
This is important picture.
So here is time.
Here is population.
Here's, maybe it started there.
This is times 0.
And now I want to graph this.
I want to graph that function.
Really, this is where
we're going somewhere.
What happens for a long time?
At t equal infinity, what
happens to the population?
Does it grow, like e to the t?
Just remember the examples here.
We had a growth like e to the t.
We had a growth faster than e
to the t that actually blew up.
What about this guy?
What will happen as t goes to
infinity with that population?
It goes to?
AUDIENCE: A over b.
PROFESSOR: A over b.
A over b.
That's the key number
in the whole thing.
It keeps growing, but it
never passes a over b.
This is y at infinity.
That's the final population.
So how does it do this?
If I draw this graph-- and
what about negative time?
Let's go backwards in time.
What is it at t
equals minus infinity?
Then you really see
the whole curve.
At t equal minus infinity,
what is this doing?
AUDIENCE: 0 infinity.
PROFESSOR: It's 0.
Good.
T equal minus infinity,
this is enormous.
This is blowing up.
It's in the denominator.
We're dividing by it.
So the whole thing
is going to 0.
So here's what the
logistic curve looks like.
It creeps up.
And it's beautifully, there's
a point of symmetry here.
The growth is increasing here.
And then, as a point of
inflection you could say,
growth is bending
upwards for a while.
At this point, it starts
bending downwards.
From that point on, ooh,
let's see if I can draw it.
It'll get closer, and
exponentially close.
That wasn't a bad picture.
The population here is half way.
Here, the population, the
final population, is a over b.
And just by beautiful symmetry,
the population here is a 1/2
of a over b.
At this point.
If this was the actual
population of the world
we live in-- I think we're
pretty close to this point.
I believe, well, of course,
nobody knows the numbers,
unfortunately, because
the model isn't perfect.
If the model was perfect, then
we could just takes the census
and we would know a and b.
But the model isn't that great.
But it's sort of, we're at
a very interesting time,
close to a very
interesting time.
I believe that with reasonable
numbers, this a over b
might be maybe 12 billion.
And we might be, I think we're
a little above six billion.
I think so.
So we're a little bit past it.
This is now.
This is halfway.
That's the halfway point.
It's perfectly symmetric.
It's called an S curve.
And many, many equations in
math biology involve S curves.
So math biology often gives
rise, with simple models,
to a kind of problem
we've had here
with a quadratic term
slowing things down.
Enzymes, all kinds of.
Ordinary differential
equations are core ideas
in a lot of topics, lot
of areas of science.
OK.
Do I want to say more about
the logistic equation?
I guess I do want to
distinguish one thing.
Yeah.
One thing about logistic
equations and will of course
come back to this.
OK.
Let me look at that
logistic equation.
Here's my equation.
So I've managed to solve it.
Fine.
Great.
Even graph it.
But let me come back
to the question,
suppose I just look at.
I can see two constant
solutions, two steady states,
two solutions where
the derivative is 0.
So nothing will happen.
So in other words, I want to set
this thing set to 0 equal to 0
to find steady solutions.
Steady means the
derivative is 0.
So this side has to be 0.
So what are the two possible
steady states where, if y of 0
is there, it'll stay there?
AUDIENCE: 0.
PROFESSOR: 0.
Y equals 0 is one.
And the other?
AUDIENCE: A over b.
PROFESSOR: Is a over b.
So steady equal to 0.
And I get two steady states.
Let me call them
capital Y equals 0
because that's certainly 0
of, if we have 0 population,
we'll never move.
Or setting this to
0, ay is by squared
cancel y's divide by b a over b.
So the two steady
states are here.
That's a steady state and
that's a steady state.
Those are the only
two in this problem.
You see how easy that was
to find the steady states?
That's an important thing to do.
And then the other important
thing to do is to decide,
are those steady states stable?
When the population's
near a steady state,
does it approach that, does
it go toward that steady state
or away?
So what's the answer?
For this steady state, that
steady state, y is a over b.
Is that stable or unstable?
So I'll write the word stable.
And I'm prepared to put in "un,"
unstable, if you want me to.
This is a key, key idea.
And with nonlinear
equations, you
can answer this stability
stuff without formulas.
Without formulas.
That's the nice thing.
And then that comes
in a later class.
But here's a perfect example.
So do we approach this
answer or do we leave it?
We approach it, the solutions.
This is stable, yes.
And here's the other
stationary point,
capital Y. The other steady
state is that nothing happens.
So now if I'm close to that, if
y is a little number, like 2,
will that 2 drop to 0, will
it approach this steady state,
or will it leave it?
AUDIENCE: Leave it.
PROFESSOR: Leave it.
So this steady state is.
AUDIENCE: Unstable.
PROFESSOR: Unstable.
Unstable.
Right.
With linear equations,
we really only
had one steady state, like 0.
Once it started, it
took off forever.
Here, it doesn't
go infinitely high.
It bends down again
to that limit,
that carrying capacity is
what it's called, a over b.
I guess I hope you
think a nonlinear
equation like got a
little more to it.
Little more interesting, but
a little more complicated,
than linear equations.
Yep.
And similarly, the
rocket equation, we
could at the right time soon in
the course, ask the same thing,
a rocket equation was
something like that.
What are the steady states?
Are they stable?
Are they unstable?
Can you find a formula?
Here.
This.
We got a formula.
And there are other nonlinear
equations, which we'll see.
OK.
I could create more
separable equations,
but I guess I hope that you
see with separable equations,
you just separate them
and integrate a y integral
and a t integral.
Is that OK any question on
this nonlinear separable stuff?
Differential equations
courses and the subject
tends to be types of
equations as can solve.
And then there are a hell of a
lot of equations that are not
on anybody's list, where
you could maybe solve them
by an infinite series, but
not by functions that we know.
OK.
I'm ready to do the
other topic for today.
It's the topic that I
left incomplete on Monday.
So I'm staying with
first order equations,
but actually this topic is
essential for second order
equations.
So I'm going to
topic two for today.
So topic two will
involve complex numbers.
So we have to deal
with complex numbers.
And the purpose of introducing
these complex numbers
is to deal with what we met
last time when the right hand
side, the forcing
term, was a cosine.
Typical alternating current,
oscillating, rotating,
rotation.
All these things
produce trig functions.
Maybe rotation is more of
a mechanical engineering
phenomenon.
Alternating current more
of an EE phenomenon.
But they're always there.
And what was the point?
The point was we had
some linear equation,
and we had some forcing by
something like cos omega t.
Or it could be A cos omega
t and B sine omega t.
Either just cosine alone, or
maybe these come together.
And then the
solution was y equals
some combination
of those same guys.
In other words,
what I'm saying is
cosines are nice right
hand forcing functions.
Fortunately, because we
see them all the time.
But they do lead to
cosines and sines.
I emphasized that last time.
If we just have cosines
in the forcing function,
we can't expect that
there's any damping,
we can't expect only cosines.
We have to expect some sines.
In other words, we have to
deal with combinations of them.
And the question is, how do you
understand cos omega t plus 3.
Or let me take a first example.
Example-- cos t plus sine t.
That's a perfect example.
So what is omega here in this
example that I'm starting with?
AUDIENCE: 1.
PROFESSOR: 1.
So I just read off
the coefficient of t
is 1, 1 hertz here.
But we have got
this combination.
And the question is, how do
we understand that cosine
plus sine?
Two very simple functions, but
they're added, unfortunately.
And there's a much
better way to write this
so you really see it.
You really see this.
That's called a sinusoid.
And the rule that
want to focus on now
is that everything of that kind,
of this kind, of this kind,
of a cosine plus a sine, can
be compressed into one term.
One term.
Of course, it's got
to have two constants
to choose because
that had an a and a b.
This had an m and an n.
This had a 1 and a 1.
But the term I'm looking
for is some number R
times a pure cosine of omega
t, but with a phase shift.
So you see there are two
numbers here to choose.
It's really like going
from rectangular to polar.
Say in complex
numbers, let's just
remember the first fact
about a complex number.
If the real part is 3, and the
imaginary part is, let's say 2,
then here's a complex
number, 3 plus 2 i.
So this was the real axis.
This was the imaginary axis.
I went along 3, I went up
2, I got to that number.
There it is.
I plotted the number 3 plus
2 i in the complex plane.
And for me, that number
3 plus and so on,
really saying
something important.
And maybe it's not entirely new.
I'm saying something important
about complex numbers,
this is their rectangular form.
Something plus something.
That form is nice to add
to another complex number.
If I added 3 plus 2 i to 1
plus i, what would I get?
AUDIENCE: 4 plus 3 i.
PROFESSOR: 4 plus 3 i.
But if I multiply,
multiply, 3 plus 2 i times,
let's say I square it.
I multiply 3 plus
2 i by 3 plus 2 i.
What do I get?
If I do it with this
rectangular form, I get a mess.
I can't see what's happening.
It's the same over here.
This is like having a 1
and a 1, with an addition.
This is like a polar
form where it's one term.
OK.
So let me answer the
question here and then let
me answer the question there.
And then you've got a good shot
at what complex numbers can do,
and why we like the polar form
for squaring, for multiplying,
for dividing.
What's the polar form?
Well, I'm using
that word "polar"
in the same way we
use polar coordinates.
What are the polar
coordinates of this point?
They're the radial
distance, which is what?
So what's that distance?
That's the R you could say.
It corresponds to this R here.
So I'm just using Pythagoras.
That hypotenuse is what?
AUDIENCE: Square root of 13.
PROFESSOR: Square root of 13.
Thanks.
9 plus 4, square root of 13.
And what's the
other number that's
locating this in
polar coordinates?
The angle.
And the angle.
What can we say
about that angle?
Let's call it phi
is-- what's the angle?
Well, it's some number.
It's between 0 and pi
over 2, I'm sure of that.
What do I know about that angle?
I know that this
is 2 and this is 3.
So that's telling me the angle.
Well, what is that really
telling me immediately?
It's telling me the.
AUDIENCE: Tangent.
PROFESSOR: Tangent of the angle.
So the tangent of the
angle is 2 over 3.
And the magnitude is
square root of 13.
OK.
So those beautiful
numbers, 2 and 3,
have become a little weirder.
Square root of 13,
inverse tangent of 2/3.
You could say, well,
that's not so nice.
What was I going to do?
I was going to try
squaring that number.
So if I square 3 plus 2 i, or
if I take the 10th power of 3
plus 2 i, or the exponential,
all these things,
then I'm happy with
polar coordinates.
Like, what would be the
magnitude of the square?
And where will the square
of that number, so I want
to put in 3 plus 2 i squared,
which I can figure out
in rectangular, of
course-- a 9, and 6 i,
or 12 i, or 4 i squared,
stuff like that.
It's not pleasant.
What's the magnitude,
what's the R for this guy?
What's the size of
that number squared?
Yes?
Say that again.
AUDIENCE: 13.
PROFESSOR: 13.
Right.
I just have to square this
square root so I get 13.
And the angle will be, what's
the angle for the square there?
I don't want a number.
I guess I'm just doing this.
R e to the i phi
squared is R squared.
And what's the angle here?
E to the i phi squared
is e to the 2 i phi.
It's the angle doubled.
E to the 2 i phi.
The angle just went
from phi to 2 phi.
The lengths went from
square root of 13 to 13.
Squaring, multiplying is
nice with complex numbers.
Maybe can I before I go on
and on about complex numbers,
I should ask you, how many
know all this already?
Complex numbers are familiar?
Mostly.
Correctly, with a wiggle.
OK.
I won't go more about
complex numbers.
Let me come back to
my question here.
Let me come back
to the application.
So here it is with
complex numbers.
Here it is with sinusoids.
And the little
beautiful bit of math
is that the sinusoid
question goes completely
parallel to the complex
number question.
So you have an idea on
those complex numbers.
We'll see them again.
Let me go to this.
So I want this to be
the same as this, OK.
Maybe I'm going to have to
use a new board for this.
Can I start a new board?
So I want cos t
plus sine t to be
some number R times
cosine of t 1.
I can see omega's 1, so I just
put to 1 minus some angle.
OK.
And I want to choose R and
phi to make that right.
You see what I like about it?
This tells me the magnitude
of the oscillation.
It tells me how
loud the station is.
When I see cos t and,
separately, sine t,
or I might see 3
cos t and 2 sine t.
3 cos t is a cosine curve.
2 sine t is a sine
curve shifted by 90.
I put them together, it
bumps, it bumps, bumps.
Not completely clear.
It seems to me just beautiful
that if I put together
a cosine curve that we
know, that starts at 0,
with a sine curve
that starts at 0,
the combination
is a cosine curve.
Isn't that nice?
I mean, you know,
that sometimes math
gets worse and worse
whatever you do.
But this is really nice that
we can put the two into one.
But you see, it's going
to-- well, let's do it.
What would R and phi be here?
So I'll use a trig fact here.
A cosine of a
difference of angles,
so this is R times cosine
t, do you member this?
This was the whole point
of going to high school.
Plus sine t sine phi.
So now, how do I get R and phi?
I use the same idea
that worked last time.
I match the cosine terms
and I match the sine terms.
So the cosine t has a 1.
1 cosine t is R cos phi.
That's what's
multiplying cosine t.
And the sine t has a 1.
And that has to agree
with R sine phi.
So I'm in business if I
solve those two equations.
And well, they're
not linear equations.
But I can solve them.
Of course, the one fact
that you never forget
is that sine squared
plus cosine squared is 1.
Right?
So if I square that one, and
square that one, and add,
what will I get?
1 squared and 1 squared will
be 2, on the left hand side.
On the right hand side, I'll
have R squared cos squared,
R squared cos squared, and
plus R squared sine squared.
And what's that?
What's R squared cosine squared
plus r squared sine squared?
AUDIENCE: R squared.
PROFESSOR: It's just R squared.
So all that added
up to R squared.
In other words, it's just
like polar coordinates.
R is the square root of 2.
That's telling us the
magnitude of the response.
Square root of 2.
You see, it's just
like complex numbers.
It's like the cosine
gave us a real part
and the sine gave us
an imaginary part.
And R was the hypotenuse.
And that's really nice.
So R is the square root of 2.
OK.
Now, the angle is
never quite as nice.
But how can we get something
about an angle out of there?
All we could get
in this case here
was the tangent of the angle.
And I'll be happy
with that again here
because it's a totally
parallel question.
How am I going to get
the tangent of the angle?
What do I have?
From these two equations,
I want to eliminate R.
So how do I eliminate R?
What do I do?
Divide.
I guess if I want
tangent sine over cosine,
I'll divide this one in the
top by this one in the bottom.
So I take the ratio.
That'll cancel the Rs perfectly.
It'll leave me with 10 phi.
And here it happens to be 1.
OK.
So what have I learned?
I've learned that when
these two add up together,
they equal what?
R square root of 2.
You see how easy it is.
Square root of 2 came from
the square root of 1 plus.
It's like Pythagoras.
Pythagoras going
in circles, really.
Times the cosine of t minus.
And what is phi?
Its tangent is 1, so
what's the angle phi?
AUDIENCE: Pi over 4.
PROFESSOR: Pi over 4.
Right.
So that's the
sinusoidal identity
when the numbers are 1 and 1.
But you saw the general rule.
Let me just take it.
Suppose this is the output, and
cos omega t plus n sine omega
t.
What is the gain?
What's the magnitude,
the amplitude,
the loudness of the volume in
this when I'm tuning the radio?
What's the R for this guy?
What's this R?
If we just follow the same idea.
So if we have m times a
cosine and n times a sine,
what's your guess?
What's your guess
for R, the magnitude?
I'm guessing a
square root of what?
Yeah?
You got.
What is it?
n squared--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: Plus n squared.
Way to go.
M squared plus N squared.
And the angle is
like the phase shift.
I'm not great at
graphing, but let
me try to go back to
my simple example.
If I tried to add up on
the same graph cosine
t, which would start from 1 and
drop to 0, go like that, right?
Something like that
would be cosine.
And now I want to
add sine t to that.
So that climbs up to
1 back to 0, down.
And now if I add those
two, this formula
is telling me that
it comes out neat.
Neatly.
That one plus that one is
another sinusoid with height
square root of 2.
If I had different
chalk, I've got
at least a little bit different.
But does it start here?
Of course not.
It starts here, I guess.
But it goes up, right?
Because this comes down,
but this is going up.
All together, it's up
to, where is the peak?
Where is the peak on the sum?
So I'm adding, everybody
sees what I'm doing?
I'm adding a cosine
curve and a sine curve.
And it goes up.
And where does it peak?
What angle is it
going to peek at?
What's the biggest
value this gets to?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: At pi
over 4, it'll peak.
At pi over 4, it'll be the
cosine of 0, which is 1.
It's height'll be the magnitude,
the gain, square root of 2.
So it'll peak at
pi over 4, which
is probably about there, right?
Peak at pi over 4 and, I don't
know if I got it right frankly.
I did my best.
That's the sum.
That right there.
The first key point is
it's a perfect cosine.
The second key point is
it's a shifted cosine.
The third key point
is its magnitude
is the square root of 1 squared
plus 1 squared, or n squared
plus n squared, or a
squared plus b squared.
So that's the
sinusoidal identity.
A key identity and being able to
deal with forcing terms, source
terms, that are sinusoids.
OK.
Now, I'm going to take
one more step since we
have just like 10
minutes left, and let
the number i get
in here properly.
Get a complex number
to show up here.
OK.
Before I start on
this, let me recap.
Let me recap today's lecture.
It started with nonlinear
separable equations.
And a great example was the
logistic equation up there,
with the S curve.
That took half the lecture.
The second half
of the lecture has
started with things
real with sinusoids
that are combinations
of cosine and sine
and has written them
in a one term way.
And now I want to
get the same one term
picture from using
complex numbers.
OK.
And everything I
do would be based
on this great fact from Euler
that e to the i omega t.
The real part is cosine omega t.
And the imaginary
part is sine omega t.
That's a central formula.
Let me draw it rather
than proving it.
Let me draw what that means.
I'm in the complex plane again.
Real part is the cosine.
The imaginary part is the sine.
That number there
is e to the i omega
t because it's got that real
part and that imaginary part.
And what's its magnitude?
What's the R, the polar
distance for cos omega t plus,
for this number, which
is for this number?
What's the hypotenuse here?
Everybody knows.
AUDIENCE: 1.
PROFESSOR: 1.
Hypotenuse is 1.
Cos squared plus
sine squared is 1.
So e to the i omega t is
on a circle of radius 1.
That's the most important
circle in the complex world,
the circle of radius 1.
And all these points are on it.
And their angles are omega t.
And as t increases,
the angle increases,
and you go around the circle.
You've seen it.
Physics couldn't live
without this model.
OK.
So that's basically
what we have to know.
And now, how do we use it?
Well, the idea is to
deal with the equation.
Like, the equation I
had last time was dy,
dt equals y plus cos t.
That gave us some trouble
because the solution didn't
just involve cosines,
it also involved sines.
Yeah.
So I want to write that equation
differently, in complex form.
And this is the key point here.
So I'm going to look
at the equation dz,
dt equals z plus e to the i t.
Well, I'll make that
cos omega t just
to have a little more, the
units are better, everything's
better if I have
a frequency there.
Units of this are seconds
and the units of this
are 1 over seconds.
Now, question.
What's the relation
between the solution
z to that complex equation
and the solution y
to that equation?
Of course, they
have to be related,
otherwise it was stupid to
move to this complex one.
My claim is that complex
equation is easy to solve.
And it gives us the answer
to the real equation.
And what's the connection
between y and z?
AUDIENCE: So y's the real part.
PROFESSOR: Y is,
exactly, say it again.
AUDIENCE: The real part--
PROFESSOR: Of z.
Y is the real part of z.
So that gives us an idea.
Solve this equation and
take it's real part.
If I can solve this equation
without getting into cosine
and sine separately and
matching, I can stay real.
I solve the equation by
totally real methods up to now.
Now I'm going to say,
here's another approach.
Look at the complex
equation, solve it,
and take the real part.
You may prefer one method.
You may like to stay real.
In a way, it's a little
more straightforward.
But the complex one is
the one that will show us,
it brings out this R,
it brings out the gain,
it brings out the
important-- engineering
quantities are important,
if I do it this way.
Now, I believe that the
solution to that is easy.
Actually, it is included
in what I did last time.
It's a linear equation
with a forcing term
that's a pure exponential.
And what kind of
solution do I look for?
I'm looking for a
particular solution.
If I see an exponential
forcing term, I say, great.
The solution will
be an exponential.
So the solution will be sum.
Z is sum capital Z
e to the i omega t.
Plug it in.
What happens if I plug
that in to find capital Z,
which is just a number?
Right.
This is my method.
This is a linear equation, with
one of those cool right hand
sides, where the solution has
the same form with a constant,
and I just have to
find that constant.
So I plug it in.
Dz, dt.
Take the derivative of this,
z i omega will come down.
E to the i omega t.
Z is just this, z
to the i omega t.
And this is just 1
e to the i omega t.
So I plugged it in, hoping
things would be good.
And they are because
I can cancel e
to the i omega t, that's the
beauty of exponentials, leaving
just a 1 there.
So what's capital Z?
What's capital Z then?
I've got a z here.
I better bring it over here.
And I've got the 1 there.
I think the z is 1 over.
When I bring that z over here,
do you see what I'm getting?
It's all multiplying
this e the i omega t.
It's a number there.
Z times i omega and
comes over as a minus z.
What do I have
multiplying z here?
I see the i omega.
And what else have I
got multiplying the z?
AUDIENCE: Minus.
PROFESSOR: A negative 1 because
it came over with a minus sign.
Done.
Equation solved.
Complex equation solved.
So the point is, the complex
equation was a cinch.
We just assumed the right
form, plugged it in,
found the number, we're done.
But there's one more
step, which is what?
Take the real part.
So I have to take the
real part of this.
So the correct answer is y is
the real part of that number, 1
over i omega minus 1
times e to the i omega t.
I'm tempted to stop there, but
just with a little comment.
How am I going to
find that real part?
And what form will it have?
What form will that
real part have?
Yeah, maybe just to say
what form will it have?
The real part, it's
going to be a sinusoid.
But I have a complex number
multiplying this guy.
The real part is going to
be exactly of the form we--
well, of course, it
had to be the form
because that was another
way to solve the equation.
It's going to be some number.
And I'll call it g, for
gain, times the real part.
And so the real part
will be a cosine.
Yeah, it's just perfect.
A cosine of omega t.
And there'll be a phase.
Yeah.
i haven't taken that step fully.
I got to that fully.
And then I said that that, if
I use some complex arithmetic,
will come out to be this.
And you see the beauty
of that answer, which
was way better than a
sum of sines and cosines.
We see the gain.
We see the amplitude.
And we see the phase shift.
Yeah.
So I don't know, that
would be a good exercise
in complex numbers.
Find g and find phi, in taking
the real part of this thing.
Yeah.
It's a pure exercise in
using complex numbers.
I don't feel like
doing it today.
If we do it, you just
see a lot of formulas.
Here, you see the point.
The point was that
the complex equation
could be solved in one line.
We just did it.
But that left us the problem
of taking the real part.
That was the e to
the i omega t there.
Left us the problem of
taking the real part.
And that's a practice
with complex arithmetic.
So you've got the choice.
Either stay real--
sign plus cosine.
And then use the sinusoidal
identity, polar form.
Or get the polar form from here.
Same answer both ways.